key bonjour à tous je m'appelle adrien
cours des mois c'est sébastien heymans
on se connaît tous les deux depuis un
bon bout de temps ouais moi j'avais
j'avais 12 ans ouais et on vient vous
expliquer notre projet alors ce projet
c'est le catamaran 1,5 sur l'atlantique
donc début septembre dernier on est
parti pour 40 jours d'aventuré à la
voile sur un tout petit bateau pas
habitable donc pas de cabine et on a
profité de chacune de nos étapes pour
partir à la chasse aux déchets sur les
plages sur lesquelles on s'arrêtait
alors quand on a réfléchi à une idée une
espèce d'image pour pour illustrer un
peu ce qui représente un tel voyage sur
un bateau pareil on est tombé assez
d'accord pour dire que c'est est
comparable à une aventure sur une
trottinette des mères ouais tout à fait
en fait de trop grosses vagues détroit
ouvre trou sur une route mais on a vite
fait ce faire bâle enfin de se faire
balancer au dessus du bolide nous
arriver dans les ports entre les entre
les gros bateaux et les ferries c'est un
peu comparable à ce que serait une
arrivée d'un trottine et east
dans une station service entre les gros
camions et les voitures ça ressemble pas
mal à ce que enfin c'était pas mal
comparables oui c'est ça l'image d'une
aventure à bord d'une trottinette des
maires ça représente pas mal l'état
d'esprit du projet on aime dire que
l'idée est née au guatemala ça fait un
peu aventurier à toute épreuve puis
c'est pas faut donc on en profite pour
se raconter un peu après le secondaire
on est partis chacun de notre côté pour
un voyage d'un an en amérique centrale
il y en a eu l'occasion de voyager
quelques semaines ensemble là bas mais
l'amérique centrale c'est loin bas les
gens ils ont une conception différente
que nous du tri sélectif
bah voilà malheureusement une fenêtre de
but ça peut très vite devenir une
poubelle à ciel ouvert même je bats la
holy de ramasser du bois sec pour
allumer un feu le plastique ça marche
super bien il y en a pas mal en dessous
de nos pieds donc voilà c'est la
première chose qui nous ont faits qui
nous ont fait réfléchir en fait tu as eu
à notre consommation abusive de
plastique en fait c'est aussi au
guatemala que naît l'idée pour la
première fois d'un voyage à bord d'une
embarcation un peu trop petit pour faire
vraiment sérieux on a eu l'occasion de
s'embêter pas mal de temps au bord de
l'eau et ça nous a fait cogiter pour
combler l'ennui on devient un peu
créatif on a inventé des petits plans un
peu farfelu de descendre de deux fleuves
à la rame sur des radeaux de fortune
heureusement pour notre survie on a mis
en oeuvre aucun de ces plans sauf celui
qu'on avait eu là bas de parcourir les
côtes sur un tout petit catamaran et
donc voilà on rentre chacun la maison
c'est comment ses études de droit à lui
c est moi mais étude d'image alliée à
des et puis voilà notre route notre
routine reprend ses droits
ouais on rentre chez nous tranquillement
et puis on court ensemble assez assez
régulièrement et et un jour adri revient
vers moi avec cette idée qu'on avait eu
de voyager sur un tout petit kata un peu
ridicule le long des côtes
je suis en été dans ce petit chemin
justement cbt directement super chaud on
commence à arriver très vite du projet
quand est-ce qu'on part où est ce qu'on
va comment est-ce qu'on va garder notre
calme sont au sec
nous voilà les premières qu'elles sont
les premières questions commencent à
arriver
et le co des caleçons de voix la
première qu'ils ont commencé à arriver
le projet dont le nom d'un zinc arrive
aussi à ce moment-là zinc pourquoi parce
que zinzins c'est un projet un peu fou
et zinc basse et le veuf c'est le verlan
deux cousins c'est un truc de rappeurs
que j'écoutais mon frère et puis c'était
un chouette tournon cause de la f1 ça
nous faisait bien rigoler c'était
vraiment excellent du coup on l'idée du
projet fleuri un peu dans notre tête on
se lance on se donne 40 jours on va
parcourir les côtes entre la belgique et
l'espagne sur notre petit 40 catamarans
de plage donc voilà ça c'est le côté
plus sportif du projet mais aujourd'hui
c'est assez difficile de passer à côté
d'un des tous gros scoop du moment c'est
que l'être l'être humain n'est pas en
train de rendre particulièrement service
à la planète terre voilà ça c'est le
tracé qu'on a fait
l'être humain ne rend pas vraiment
service à la planète terre pour l'a pas
fait mais pas jusqu'en espagne en
bretagne enfin quoiqu'il en soit il ya
pas mal de problématiques
environnementales actuelles il y en a
une qui nous touche particulièrement
c'est le fait que les océans sert
véritablement de dépotoir à l'humanité
alors nous on aime beaucoup la mer et
donc à force de s'intéresser un peu au
sujet ça finit par faire naître en nous
une envie de faire un petit quelque
chose avec les moyens à notre
disposition on est loin des experts en
biologie marine on n'a pas de
compétences particulières en écologie et
on n'a pas réussi à inventer une machine
qui nous permettra de d'aller ramasser
les déchets à notre place sur la plage
donc ce qu'on trouve de mieux cette
profiter de ce voyage qu'on prévoyait de
faire un petit catamaran le long de
centaines de kilomètres de côtes pour
aller mettre nos quatre mains à la pâte
et débarrassé certaines plages sur notre
route de leurs déchets en plus de ça on
vit vraiment une époque où les gens
passent un temps fou sur les réseaux
sociaux
c'est devenu une source d'information
donc il n'est pas toujours bien utiliser
mais en tout cas utiliser super
largement et seulement si on a remarqué
un truc c'est que de ce qu'on voit tous
les jours
ben ça change un petit peu notre manière
de voir les choses et d'agir et voilà on
n'est pas né on n'est pas né conscient
des différentes des différents enjeux
climatiques bas on l'aimé on est devenus
et on est devenu grâce à des articles d
des vidéos qui nous ont qui nous ont
choqués et donc c'est pour ça qu'on
s'est dit que ce serait super d'utiliser
tout cet outil donc les réseaux sociaux
pour faire accélérer ce mouvement de
sensibilisation auprès des gens qui nous
suivent d'abord et puis alors peut-être
encore plus loin si si c'est possible
voilà c'est ça vu qu'on a été
sensibilisé via les réseaux sociaux
on s'est dit qu'en partageant notre
aventure sur ces mêmes réseaux sociaux
on finira peut-être par déclencher un
petit déclic peut-être inconscient même
mais d'abord dans notre entourage et
puis chez tous les gens qui nous ont
suivis à force de partager des petites
vidéos qu'on les trouve amusante en tout
cas nous et dans lesquels les mots
plastique et des chaires sorte
sipa dans chaque phrase en tout cas très
régulièrement peut-être qu'on finira par
faire naître une sorte d'allergie
général au plastique parmi parmi notre
entourage et ce serait déjà une belle
réussite
mais donc voilà on crée une petite page
facebook sur laquelle hubwoo publie un
peu l'avancée du projet puis entre les
examens et les cours auxquels on assiste
pas assez souvent au bout de nos parents
bah on va là on arrive à monter des
fonds grâce au crowdfunding au
sponsoring
jusqu'à ce jusqu'à ce qu'on arrive à
avoir assez de sous pour acheter ce qui
allait devenir notre monture notre
fidèle destrier
le catamaran zinc alors c'est un a créé
un terreau 18 et bat pour ceux qui sont
pas trop calé en voile en gros c'est un
catamaran donc sans caleçon cabine avec
juste un trampoline des quatre mètres
carrés est tendue entre deux coques donc
voilà on a fini par avoir ce bateau mais
ça veut pas dire qu'on est prêt pour
autant à ce moment là on a dit se
préparer petit à petit pendant l'année
et en fait pour être franc ça a été un
peu la panique dans les derniers jours
avant le décollage
on était sûr de rien ce qui a fait qu'on
était sûr de rien c'est que la majorité
de notre préparation c'était de
l'improvisation parce qu'on n'avait pas
de petit carnet de commandes préparer un
trampoline flottant pour 40 jours de mer
donc on a dû inventer une partie de
notre notre équipement et le jour du
départ c'était un tout gros stress parce
qu'on se demandait on était content de
partir enfin mais on se demandait
vraiment si le bateau allait aller tenir
la route voyez pas nous claquer entre
les mains mais donc voilà le la veille
du 4 septembre c'était le grand départ
on est d'ailleurs la première fois
l'étanchéité de notre tente sous la
drache
donc la première escale c'était
dunkerque quand on arrive à dunkerque
mais il faisait vraiment pas beau quasi
comme d'habitude et quand on est parti
le lendemain mais il est encore moins
beau et c'est même moi je ne sais pas on
était tous les deux posé sur le fin afin
de boue sur le ponton dans le
combinaison encore humide de la veille
et d'ailleurs qu'il resterait pendant
les 40 jours suivants on y reste on va
regarder la rade de dunkerque en disant
bon s comparaissent compare pas bon on a
fini par se lancer on était quand même
pas 100% convaincu de notre décision
parce que ça souffle est quand même
vachement fort et puis pour terminer
d'achever notre confiance en nous à la
fin de ce chenal de sortie il ya un type
qui vient nous rejoindre un moniteur qui
va nous rejoindre sur son os diack et
qui nous dit vous êtes sûr de vouloir y
aller sur un bateau pareil vous avez vu
comment il fait des lieux où on garde un
peu la tête haute on se dit qu'on va y
aller quand même
on stresse un peu mais au final tout se
passe bien et on continue notre route en
direction du sud à l'achat sur plastoc
d'étape en étape de ville en ville de
port en port de plage en plage ont fini
par arriver à dieppe où on a aussi des
anecdotes un peu extrême a raconté donc
on se la pète un peu devant jury
donc là ça va pas mal secoué aussi mais
le matin on partait sous le soleil une
bonne boîte de cassoulet toulousain de
800 grammes par personne pour le petit
déjeuner farniente le soleil et tout ça
et puis d'un coup le temps hh ans
complètement changé et on s'est pris d
un vent terriblement fort en pleine face
donc nous on a complètement dévier de
notre route et on partait au large et on
se rendait compte que si on s'acharnait
à vouloir arriver là où l'on comptait
arriver on allait finir de nuit en
pleine mer à 20 centimètres de l'eau ça
sur un bateau comme le nôtre ce n'est
pas souhaitable
bah ouais c'est sûr que contrairement un
voilier habitable avec une cabine on
peut pas aller se réfugier se prendre un
petit café un petit et bien le jeu a
changé me ciré se remettre au sec
ici nous en reste et a émis toute la
journée et donc quand on partait le
matin on devait casier de sueur de
l'heure à laquelle on arrivait le soir
parce qu'on ne peut pas soumettre de
rester même seulement trois heures en
plus dans nos combi pas étanche
on voit là on aurait était frigorifié
pas donc c'est lou hahn hon donc voilà
ça c'est une image d'une bonne douche
d'eau salée qu'on se prend
quotidiennement
donc voilà on décide de retourner vers
diable parce que c'est carrément
inconscient de continuer sur cette route
mais alors à la vitesse à laquelle on va
avec des vagues comme il y avait ce jour
là
le danger c'est de rattraper la vague
qui est devant celle sur laquelle on
surf et d'aller se planter dedans c'est
comme donner un énorme coup de frein
avant avec son vélo en pleine descente
se fait complètement balancer devant son
d'avant son bolide et c'est ce qui nous
est arrivé
oui tout à fait je me suis retrouvé à
essayer de faire retomber seb sur le
catamaran un peu comme un bilboquet
humain il tournait et gravitaient autour
du bateau en fait il était juste attaché
avec son harnais heureusement il est
toujours là et heureusement que vous
racontez l'histoire mais moi j'ai filé
en un seul morceau bon vent c'était pas
tous les jours des gueux on a aussi
passé pas mal de journée sous le soleil
toujours avec des tonnes et des tonnes
de cassoulet toulousain mais dans une
ambiance beaucoup plus détendue bon
convenons-en un peu au plastique parce
que c'était l'objectif de base quand
même on s'était fixé comme objectif de
nettoyer tous les soirs la plage sur
laquelle on allait s'arrêter clairement
certaines plages étaient déjà propre
avant qu'on arrive pourquoi nettoyées
assez régulièrement ou juste épargné par
les courants à cet endroit là sur
d'autres par contre c'était une autre
histoire
on a peine à imaginer que si près de
chez nous en france on puisse se trouver
des plages vraiment dans un état si six
salles n'étaient pas toujours drôle de
se mettre à ramasser des papiers par
terre après toute une journée passée à
se prendre une bonne douche mais mais on
s'y mettait
et à force de ramassage on s'est rendu
compte que ce qui était vraiment pénible
ce n'est pas tant la quantité de
plastique qu'on pouvait trouver sur une
plage même si c'est rarement ça mais
rarement du baume au coeur de voir une
plage complètement fouillé
mais c'est surtout le fait de n'être que
deux pour ramasser ses papiers fins et
plastiques c'est tous ces déchets
heureusement pour nous il fallait pour
pas mal de monde au final il ya beaucoup
de gens qui se bouge on a eu l'occasion
de rencontrer plein de monde le long de
cette le long de cette aventure des
ramasseurs enthousiaste et ça ça donne
vraiment la pêche parce qu'on se rend
compte qu'on est très loin d'être des
visionnaires avoir compris un problème
que personne n'a compris mais on fait
partie d'un grand mouvement général de
gens qui qui ont compris que la
situation était critique et qu'il
fallait faire quelque chose quoi que ce
soit et ouais par exemple la formation
alors la plage de fort mahon elle était
beaucoup plus long que les autres y
avait beaucoup plus de déchets les
déchets n'étaient pas plus funky
qu'ailleurs mais mais ce jour là quand
on est arrivé on a eu un double coup de
bol en fait on y avait le festival de la
mer dans ce village
donc premier coup de bol c'est qui avait
beaucoup de monde sur la plage donc les
gens voyaient deux jeunes ramasser des
déchets bay il avait envie de faire
qu'une seule chose c'est de nous aider
donc on a reçu pleins d le travail
avance et super vite
et deuxième chose quand on est quand on
est passé dans le festival on est tombé
sur un stade donc tenu par par une
association qui s'appelle la sonatur
libre à eux en fait ils luttent à fond
contre contre femme nettoie il nettoie
plein de plage fin de la côte française
on a discuté longtemps avec eux et
l'après midi on a ramassé pendant tout
l'après-midi a vécu et c'était super
efficace c'était super efficace et
surtout très encourageant ça nous a
donné envie de pas seulement ramasser
comme des cow boys solitaires de notre
côté mais d'aller à la rencontre
d'autres gens qui se bougeait le long
des côtes françaises et en a plein
malheureusement c'était difficile de
planifier quoi que ce soit parce que sur
notre trottinette des mères on dépend
complètement du vent pour se déplacer
mais on a quand même eu la chance de
tomber sur pas mal de gens
extraordinaires tout le tout au long du
parcours
donc voilà on peut se le dire maintenant
l'espagne c'est un petit peu ambitieux
surtout à cette période où les où les
vents soufflent dans la mauvaise
direction
quand on quand on quand on quand on
prend une carte en face de nous et qu'on
s'imaginait on s'imagine déjà en fait
traverser les océans et faire des
milliers de milles mais quand on a le
nez dessus et on a eu le nez dessus même
dedans parfois quand ça swingue et un
peu on se rend compte qu'en fait la mer
semble tellement grande que pour pouvoir
souffrir de nous de nos conneries à nous
les humains tout petit toutou frêle par
rapport à ce truc immense et dangereux
c'est pour ça que c'est difficile à
imaginer que qu'on lui fait en fait tant
de mal on est en train de on est en
train de remplacer le
le poisson qu'on surpêche par du
plastique ont sur produits et donc voilà
il lancé on va toujours debout nous
faire peur avec ses grosses vagues et
ses grosses tempêtes etc
on y fait quand même beaucoup plus de
mal que ce que lui nous on fait quoi
c'est clair et on n'est pas en train de
gagner une bague r c'est pas un un
combat où il faut le mettre ko avec le
catamaran en zinc au final si on devait
conclure un peu l'idée c'est pas de
faire un nettoyage des océans ça ferait
pas de mal mais on serait pas trop
comment s'y prendre à la force de nos
tout petits bras on a peut-être ramassés
à cette plastique pour faire une belle
pyramide des crasses ici sur cette scène
ce serait assez impressionnant si on
voyait tous à empiler ici devant vous
mais ça reste complètement ridicule à
côté de ce qu'on balance à l'eau chaque
jour d'un côté ce n'est pas non plus
parce que ça semble complètement
dérisoire qu'il faut qu'il faut rien
faire on fait ce qu'on peut avec ce
qu'on a et et bien voilà je me serais
évidemment jallet retrouvailles ou si on
n'a pas l'habitude de parler à beaucoup
de monde quand on est en mer dont les
deux donc la fin donc voilà on se
retrouve on se retrouve à akwa avec un
gros problème sur les bras et il faut
quand même faire quelque chose avec le
catamaran 5 on n'imagine pas qu'on est
la solution au problème mais on est
peut-être une des toutes petites
solutions qui viendront plic ploc
réparer le une partie du mal qu'on l'a
fait une des petites gouttes d'eau qui
viendront éteindre un incendie du
plastique dans les océans et on va se
relancer dans une nouvelle aventure
cette année ci avec un troisième larron
un troisième équipier de nouveau à la
rencontre des gens qui se bougent pour
des océans plus propre
non seulement mais aussi pour des
rivières moins polluer on continuera de
partager une petite vidéo sur facebook
en espérant que ça plaise à quelques
personnes ça peut déjà nos mamans et
puis
et puis si ça plaît à des gens peut-être
que ça fera changer quelques mauvaises
habitudes et ce serait déjà une très
belle victoire donc voila merci à tous
de nous avoir écoutés et comme le dit si
bien georges pernoud de thalassa à
bientôt et bon vent je savais qu'il
allait faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
coc